many people also think that bitcoin is a
trustless system or stateless system
that observation is easily exaggerated
let's look at the notion of it being
stateless in being beyond the control of
any government
well at one level this blockchain
remember it exists in thousands hundreds
of thousands or millions of copies
spread around the world and everybody's
got copies of it and the the miners
update it and refresh it all the time
well to the extent that the blockchain
exists out there in
internet space
and internet space isn't within the
jurisdiction of any government that's
entirely accurate to say that at that
peer-to-peer level you could argue that
the transactions in bitcoin and other
similar systems are beyond the reach of
any government
okay
but as soon as you attempt to interact
with the real world
by either taking real value out of the
system by saying for example i want to
get cash that i can use to buy a cup of
coffee for my bitcoin
then the state has the ability to
regulate your actions because at that
point you exist in the physical world
and you're subject to the jurisdiction
of the authorities in whichever
jurisdiction you happen physically to
exist
so as soon as you try to put value into
the system or take value out of the
system
the real world the corporeal world is
interacting with the internet this vague
thing that's beyond the government
and you then give rise to the ability of
the government to exercise jurisdiction
over the persons engaging with the
internet or the bitcoin or the value
that's going into or out of the system
so again
it depends on how you look at it
if you just want to limit it to the
system itself and say there's no
connection to the real world great
but then bitcoin is just a giant video
game and it's never a situation where
value is moving into or out of the
system
as soon as you let value move into and
out of the system the government has a
lever
it's got a hook it's got jurisdiction
that it can exercise over the people
moving the value into and out of the
system and that's extraordinarily
important
which brings us to the question of trust
many people interact with bitcoin and
other forms of crypto through exchanges
well
as soon as you're interacting through an
exchange
guess who you're trusting
you're trusting the exchange
what if the exchanges loses your crypto
what if the crypto gets stolen from the
exchange what if it turns out that the
exchange is run by a bunch of crooks who
pack up one day and head off to
minsk
all right or kiev or somewhere else and
you never see them again all right so as
soon as you're dealing with any
intermediary in the crypto space
and a very very large percentage of
smaller investors are dealing with
intermediaries
you're trusting somebody
you're not you know it's not a situation
where you've got to trust the people
that are operating with the system
that's operating at the crypto level
it's the intermediary through which
you're putting in value and taking the
value out
if you're not going to rely on one of
these intermediaries you're typically
going to have to store information you
have to store your code someplace else
and at that point you've got to trust
your system
not to lose your code or not to have
your code valued and then have the
ability to transfer the code to people
to whom you want to transfer it when the
time comes to transfer it so the notion
of
these systems really being stateless
is easily exaggerated
and the notion of the systems being
trustless
is also easily exaggerated we're human
beings
we all exist in physical forms
at that level governments have
jurisdiction and control
over all of us
and the idea of having something with
value where you don't have to trust
anybody else about that value
it's pretty hard to do